I saw you in person yesterday me being
at the studio you lost quite a bit of
weight huh yeah I lost a little bit of
weight you know what I thought he had
yet because your face looks thinner how
much did you lose I lost about 30 pounds
nice OIC OIC I did not do it it's so
funny I saw s the first thing s says to
me you're doing OIC right like no I'm
not doing OIC uh I was actually inspired
by Jason I did Neutra system for about a
month and a half and then my wife's like
you're hooked on that you got to
gradually work your way off of it
because you'll gain an all back and I
gradually shifted off of it and now um I
eat a lot less and um exercising and
actually taking care of better care of
myself what kind of exercise you doing
uh I play pickle ball at least twice a
week and uh wow no I go I go for Robin I
had to say attitude as you okay I'm like
come on I'm not this is a geriatric
sport it's not even a sport I'm not
going to play it and I went out there
and played it and actually enjoyed it
and um you work up a sweat after a
couple hours out there so and I take up
most of the court so I'm I'm actually
pretty good at it so that helps and then
every day I go for I go for a walk
minimum half hour just a long walk and
get out and um my ass is still huge but
I feel better which is good good all
right good I first I looked you over I
thought you were sick but uh then they
informed me you were it was
intentional